I think part of it though is just like
the gradually but then all at once or
slowly but then suddenly I think is
another one like Unchained guys use that
the idea really comes down to what are
the accelerant and at some point do you
hit a point of no return right like I
caught like burning the boats right in
the whole idea of burning the boats is
when you go and you find new land you
know back in the day you're not actually
committed to staying until you burn the
boats when you burn the boats but you
can't go back right so when do we get to
that point well here we are burning the
boats right now I think Ovid was an
example of burning the boats right it's
you know we we just burnt the you know
the the interest rate boat then we burnt
the QE infinity boat so so those two
boats are burnt now what else is that
like the number of boats that are
available to burn to basically discredit
the existing system you know becoming
less and less numerous I mean I always
say kovin was the one of the best
marketing campaigns for Bitcoin in
history because like the that these are
the events that I just remember what I
was gonna be analogy I was gonna use
earlier was on the smartphone analogy
like we can all remember a time before
smart phones like when we all had flip
phones or their shitty Nokia banana
phones and all that sort of stuff we
remember the dumb phones and we remember
when that was ubiquitous and we also
remember when you know modern times now
like when smart phones are completely
ubiquitous but that transition period I
can't exactly remember that I don't
really I'm not really clear on when we
had like a real good mix of smart phones
and dumb phones at the same time like
that had that phase shift like happened
so quickly and I think you know we were
obviously not at that point yet with
Bitcoin but I think over the next decade
the the question is gonna shift from you
know people asking today's like why the
hell would you have Bitcoin to sometime
in the next decade the question will be
why the hell don't you have Bitcoin like
so that strange
look like that the question will change
and I mean
maybe maybe the trigger is gonna be
something as crazy as other a friend of
mine is another Bitcoin er in Australia
Hosmer kook he he put a tweet out a
little while ago saying my prediction
for next year is 40,000 in the Dow and
40% unemployment and that that to me
like I mean as crazy as that sounds like
what we're seeing right now with these
supposed solution to the kovat problem
is you know this printing of money
bailing out of the big boys and all this
sort of stuff is we're actually tearing
society apart and we're you know we have
this illusion of prosperity in the stock
market you know basically the Nasdaq
almost back at all-time highs
I mean Shopify blown through its high as
Amazon's blown through as high as Tesla
basically back at highs you know uber
and lyft the back at you know beyond
their December price it's such insanity
but at the same time we've got almost
30% unemployment who has nobody's
working
everyone's at home and you know
everyone's living on a $1,200
you know handout it's like it's some
Main Street and Wall Street are
completely diverging it's madness and
and maybe maybe that's what triggers
people to say you know I've had enough